The Joe Rogan experience.
We both been busy.
It's crazy.
And in the meantime we'd became legal.
Yes,
you guys were at the forefront,
man,
you guys were way ahead.
You were ahead of everybody.
You know,
we took a shot,
he took a shot,
you know,
it's donors and advocates and whatnot.
You know,
we were stoners it first.
Right.
You know,
that's how you start.
Like,
you know,
your friend says,
hey man,
try this.
Or you're the one who says try this.
Right?
It's one or the other.
And you know,
eventually you start getting into the high times magazines and stuff like that
and looking at the,
you know,
the centerfold pictures of the weed.
But also we like,
we like to read too easily.
So,
you know,
we'd get into some of the activism aspect of it as well.
And that's when we heard names like Jack Herrera,
who pretty much opened our eyes to everything.
And then,
you know,
I think we became real advocates.
You know,
at first,
you know,
we thought we were,
sort of,
we read the high times magazines that we were stoners,
so we thought we were advocates,
but like in reading what other freedom fighters were actually doing out there
and protest and rallies and all that stuff.
You know,
we,
we really weren't advocates.
Like we thought we became that later for sure.
Yeah.
Jack was way,
way,
way ahead of the curve.
He's in such an interesting story.
Uh,
rest in peace because he was a Goldwater Republican,
you know,
he was just a button down old school republican.
Then he got a girlfriend and then her girlfriend and got him smoking weed and
then all of a sudden he's like,
man,
this is fucking amazing.
God.
Why am I such a Dick?
What's wrong with me?
Who am I?
What am I doing in my life?
Absolutely.
It totally flipped his life around.
The emperor wears no clothes.
The fucking great book,
man.
Yeah,
it holds,
it holds strong to this day because everything that he said in the book is sort
of happening right now.
All the stuff that they,
you know,
they,
uh,
tried to prevent from happening through all the anti cannabis propaganda.
Yeah.
You see it now and now you see those very companies tried to get into the
industry if they were always on the outside of the waiting,
you know,
there is only good at the launching block,
not quite ready to run,
but uh,
any minute now it's going to get legal.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
you know,
they're,
they're lying in wait with fields like acreage that no one can ever come close
to probably.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
the thing I heard maybe like five years ago before it was legal in Denver or a
bit longer than that before we got legalization here,
um,
that,
you know,
companies like Philip Morris and you know,
companies like that we're already buying land in already.
I'm trademarking names,
you know,
for some of the cannabis that we know today so that when they come into the
game,
you know,
they have ownership on some of the names in some of the brands and trademarks
and stuff like that.
To that end,
obviously the acreage to,
you know,
grow vast sums of cannabis.
Yeah.
You know,
who knows how true that is,
but I don't doubt some of that.
I don't doubt it either.
As sneaky as shit was Ohio,
Ohio was,
they were trying to make it legal,
but if they were going to make it legal,
there was only like it was took two companies that were on Jamie's from Ohio,
think like four.
But I think that is how it went.
They were the only ones going to be allowed to grow it and sell it.
Like fuck,
fuck,
fuck you monopoly.
That is not legal weed.
That is you being a cunt.
That's monopoly.
Yeah.
And it's crazy,
you know?
Yeah.
Because you know,
you had like people that got those uh,
licenses or permits or whatever that had no knowledge on,
on,
on the cannabis culture or,
or business how to cultivate and,
and how to run retail stores or any of that.
They didn't have any of that knowledge.
And you know,
Dell usually give it to an insider because they know how much money they stand.
To me that's like if there was just one distribution center,
right,
and everybody has to go through that distribution center,
how much money does that distribution center make me?
Cause he got to pay for your shit to go there.
And then you know,
who knows if it,
well you know,
if it passes because you know as a cultivator what you did so you'll know it'll
pass cause it's clean,
but you still got to pay that fee every time and it's got to go through them.
Fortunately here in California,
you know,
they allowed people to have distribution licenses so that there's not one
distribution center because that would be a monopoly for sure.
And that's what they wanted to supposedly,
you know,
the lobbyists that,
that put 64 together,
we're trying to stop it from Vienna Monopolian uh,
corporations coming in and taking over and stuff like that.
You know,
so interesting.
Because pot is such a non corporate drug and it's such a non corporate thing
that these corporations were trying to get a grip on weed.
It just,
it seemed,
it seemed obscene.
You know,
it seemed,
it seemed disgusting.
Yeah.
It's a little out of place,
you know,
a lot on a place.
Right.
You know,
because you,
you,
you think about where it comes from and it's been outlawed for so long.
It's kind of like,
you know,
the way out alcohol was for,
for so long,
but longer than alcohol,
but it's been demonized longer.
Yes.
And now,
you know,
you have people trying to come in and throw money into it and they got,
in some of these guys don't realize it's not just about the money into it.
You got to do the diligence on what this business is.
You can't cut corners on the cultivation,
you know,
you can't cut corners on quality because people,
they're,
um,
there's more information out there.
Yeah.
You know,
so people know,
even if they're not a connoisseur as a consumer,
you know,
they can,
they can read about shit,
they could learn about stuff.
So if you're getting over on a more,
if you're putting some shit,
quality product out there,
I mean people are going to know it.
And,
and all that money that these guys put into to try and get into the cannabis
business,
they're just throwing it into the fire.
Yeah.
Some of them will come out of it,
you know,
they'll partner up with,
brands did exist and people did have knowledge,
but you know,
it's,
it's the corporations that come in,
in the next five years.
It's gonna be,
it's gonna be interesting because I do think that it's set up for them to come
in.
The taxes are so high right now for the consumer and for the cultivator and for
the retail shop that you got to survive this wash right now that's happening in
order to still be,
you know,
doing business when the corporate structure comes in because please believe
they're gonna lobby so that those taxes come down because the margins are not
right.
You know,
as a 40% tax.
Is that what it is now?
It was 39 in Denver,
right?
Yeah.
But in here in California,
it's,
you know,
40% into the consumer,
the consumer's life.
Who gives a fuck?
If I could just pull in and get some weed,
row should give a fuck.
But in comparison to alcohol,
like how much it costs,
if you go out for a night for some drinks that causeway more,
you get high for a month.
Yeah.
And what it takes to get pretty much few drinks in a night.
It depending where you go,
those fucking drinks or even doubled.
Yeah.